president Trump edge is closer to firing
robert muller vladimir putin
consolidates his grip and democrats
battle over their future lots to talk
about i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show i'm punch shrunk already
and it's just monday that's what's going
on here at the studio a little bit later
today i'm be flying out to Pennsylvania
meeting at Susquehanna University which
is happening on Tuesday and I'm speaking
at Georgetown on Wednesday so it's gonna
be a packed week full of wonderful
wonderful things and we have so many
things to talk about today including the
President of the United States who
appears to be on the verge of at least
considering maybe firing Robert Muller
maybe that's speculation maybe it's not
we'll go through all the details first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at filter by so I know there are a
lot of people who get very emotional
about the environment and there are a
lot of people who worry about the air
outside here's the fact of the matter
the air outside much cleaner than the
air inside and during winter months you
are going to be spending lots of time
inside which means that you are going to
be imbibing from the non fresh air there
which is why your filters must be clean
it's why you need to check your home's
air filter filter by is America's
leading provider of HVAC filters for
homes and small businesses and they
would like for you to breathe better
they carry over 600 different filter
sizes including custom options all
shipped free within 24 hours and those
are all manufactured right here in the
United States they offer a multitude of
ME RV options all the way up to hospital
grade so you'll be removing all that
dangerous pollen mold dust other allergy
aggravating pollution while maximizing
the efficiency of your system you're
gonna spend all winter inside make sure
you are breathing clean air right now
you can save 5% when you setup auto
delivery so you never need to think
about air filters again at my house we
always think about air filters when it's
far too late and you open up the air
filter and it turns out that there are
eight years worth of gunk on the air
filter well now I don't have to worry
about it because I subscribed over at
filter by so check it out filter by calm
that's filter bu why comm set up that
auto delivery so you never need to think
about when to replace those air filters
again again that's filter by comm filter
bu why comm go check it out right now
alright so big news over the weekend is
that President Trump thinks which honked
yes he's been tweeting that out all
morning this morning on Monday we're
shocked and I don't know that's not
really how he says it but it just feels
like it should be that way because it's
all capital letters he tweeted that out
this morning earlier he tweeted out the
Mueller problem never should have been
started in that there was no collusion
and there was no
it was based on fraudulent activities
and a fake dossier paid for by crooked
Hillary in the DNC and improperly we
improperly used in FISA Court for
surveillance of my campaign all caps
witch-hunt
so President Trump really going off now
what led all of this to happen well on
Friday afternoon the president decided
well really the DOJ decided to fire X
FBI deputy director Andrew McCabe now
Andy McCabe should have been fired long
ago if you really caught will recall
Andy McCabe was the fellow whose wife
had been paid basically by Terry
McAuliffe when she was running for
Senate in Virginia and she lost but
didn't matter she was very close to the
Clinton team Andy McCabe had been far
too close even Peter struck and Lisa
Paige the FBI agents were very
anti-trump were texting with each other
going why is he Andy still on this case
legitimately why is Andy still on this
case and then it turns out that Andy
McCabe hadn't leaked a bunch of
information to the press information
that he leaked to the press by the way
was not anti-trump information was
anti-hillary information because what he
leaks to the press apparently with the
approval of James Comey over at the FBI
was that the FBI wanted to reopen the
Hillary investigation and Barack Obama's
DOJ did not want to reopen the Hillary
investigation in the aftermath of
learning that there were Hillary Clinton
emails on Huma Abedin husband's server
on P on Anthony Weiner server okay so it
wasn't like Annie McCabe is actually
being investigated for being anti Trump
in fact what he was being investigated
for was going to the press out of school
in a way that was actually anti-hillary
but on Friday the Trump administration
decided we can't let this slide his
pensions supposed to kick in on Sunday
so we'll wait till the very last minute
then we will screw him so hard and
they'll be like Debbie Does Dallas it'll
be the worst thing ever
okay that's how that's how hard they
went after he became here's what CNN
reported interning general Jeff Sessions
fired former FBI deputy director Andrew
McCabe late Friday less than two days
shy of his retirement which is such a
burn right I mean you spend 20 years
working for a place they wait until 30
seconds before you retire and get your
pension and boom there goes your pension
ending the career of an official who had
risen to serve as second-in-command at
the bureau McCabe had more recently been
regularly taunted by President Trump and
besieged by accusations he had misled
internal investigators at the DOJ in a
blistering statement Friday night McCabe
said his firing as part of a larger
effort to discredit the FBI and the
special counsels investigation quote
this attack on my credibility is one of
a larger effort not just
slander me personally but to taint the
FBI law enforcement and intelligence
professionals more generally as part of
this administration's ongoing war on the
FBI and the efforts of the Special
Counsel investigation which continue to
this day their persistence in this
campaign only highlights the importance
of the special counsel at work and in
special counsels work Suzuki Muller's
work Trump tweeted quote Andrew McCabe
fired all caps a great day for the
hard-working men and women of the FBI a
great day for democracy capital T
sanctimonious James Comey was his boss
and made McCabe look like a squire boy
he knew all about the lies and
corruption going on at the highest
levels of the FBI okay so what exactly
is crumb talking about it's not totally
clear here is where Comey may have lied
okay so what Annie McCabe said in his
statement is that he had never talked
out of school right then when he went to
the press anonymously that had been
known by people higher up in the FBI
well there was only one person higher up
in the FBI at the time that would have
been James Comey
well James Comey had said openly this
would be this would be clip 17 James
Comey had said openly in testimony that
he had never approved any anonymous
leaking to the FBI oh there's definitely
a problem you know this would seem to
contradict what Comey said now we
already know that Comey is a leaker the
question is is he a serial leaker
because we know that after he was fired
he removed his memos which by the way I
believe we're FBI material at least
seven of them and gave them to a friend
at Columbia Law School some of which at
least the information was leaked to the
media this is an even more serious
allegation because it would be occurring
when he was director and it will raise
questions of whether Comey is not just a
leaker but a liar okay and here are a
couple of the issues that are at work
one should Andrew McKay have been fired
or was it politically motivated now the
Democrats are already coming out to
defend McCabe which is hilarious because
remember McCabe was fired for leaking
anti-hillary information to the press
that's why he was fired okay should he
have been fired
yeah he should be fired a long time ago
and not only should have been fired this
case was not brought by Attorney General
Jeff Sessions just out of out of you
know out of hand this case was brought
because the Office of Professional
Responsibility which is a nonpartisan
group inside the FBI which is known for
not going after people very hard went
really hard after Andy McCabe and said
he did something really wrong and they
gave a recommendation
to the FBI that he'd be fired and that
hits the DOJ that he'd be fired and that
his pension essentially be suspended
Donald Trump now that brings us to
question number two in question number
two is why does this matter right why
isn't it just a guy did something wrong
at the FBI now he's been fired and
McCabe's take is well Trump is gonna use
this to try and blast the entire FBI as
corrupt and then suggest that they were
out to get him and are still out to get
him and that's what the Muller
investigation is and Trump's normal
response to this would be listen I'm not
trying to stop the Muller investigation
they're doing their own thing what you
did is wrong what Muller is doing is
what Muller is doing and we'll deal with
that as it comes but unfortunately the
President of the United States continues
to make himself look more and more
guilty now so I think the president is
actually guilty of collusion no I don't
do I think the president is guilty of
obstruction no because I think it's very
difficult for the president to be guilty
of obstruction according to the laws
that are on the books right I've looked
at all those laws who have discussed
them multiple times on the program
before very difficult for the President
of the United States to actually be
guilty of obstruction with that said the
president is making himself look more
guilty by flailing around like a crazy
person like Kermit the Frog in that jiff
oh that's what the president is
basically doing on Twitter every day so
after mccabe is fired instead of him
just saying listen mccabe had to go
mccabe was a problem and then saying
Comey had to go Comey was a problem
instead it turns into Comey was a
problem McCabe is a problem Ann Muller
is a problem so President Trump tweeted
out warning Robert Muller and this
follows a week in which Muller it came
out is now investigating the financial
ties that Trump has all his financial
dealings Trump had said a long time ago
that was a red line for him that if
Muller started looking into his
financial dealings he'd seriously
consider firing Muller so if you're on
the Left here's what this lineup of
events looks like motor starts
investigating Trump's finances Trump
fires McCabe or Jeff Sessions fires
McCabe and then Trump says let's fire
Muller right it looks like you could
just skip the middleman and it looks
like Trump is trying to shut down Muller
because he doesn't like what Muller is
looking at if you're on the Left I can't
say that's completely implausible based
on the president's behavior what I
really think this is is Trump has been
wildly annoyed I know everyone in the
White House is very very annoyed with
the continuation of an investigation
they think has no merit and they feel
like it's just dogging the president day
in and day out Trump is a guy who
fixates on things right whether it is
unmentionables or whether it is Robert
Muller the man fixate on things and once
he fixate he doesn't let go
also not a joke I meant making
Trump tweeted the side he said why does
the Muller team have 13 hardened
Democrats some big crooked Hillary
supporters and zero Republicans Capital
Z another dem recently added does anyone
think this is fair and yet there is no
collusion all caps whenever I yell like
that it means it's all capital letters
um I do think there's a sort of et
Cummings quality to president Trump's
tweets you know what the random
punctuation and the capital letters it
is amusing to me
in any case Trump also tweeted out Wow
watch Comey lie under oath to Senator G
when asked have you ever said that be
senator Graham not like Original
Gangster senator G when asked have you
ever been an anonymous source or known
someone else to be an anonymous source
he said strongly never no he lied as
clearly shown on Fox and Friends okay
all of this is to say that the President
of the United States is not making
himself look particularly good here with
all of this activity even though Andy
McCabe had to go because I don't
understand what mccabe had to do with
the Muller investigation per se remember
the Muller investigation only began the
special counsel was only appointed
because the president insisted on using
rod Rosenstein as his hit man to go
after James Comey and that meant that
rod Rosenstein now became a witness in
the Comey matter which meant that he had
to appoint a special investigator it
really had nothing to do with Andy
McCabe Trump has basically seized on
every piece of evidence that there are
members of the FBI who didn't like him
as evidence that everything against him
is wrong and false and slanderous and I
don't see how you get from point A to
point B I'm willing to hear the case but
I don't really see what mccabe has to do
with the Muller investigation per se in
every attempt that Trump makes to
connect the two makes it look like he's
sort of desperate now I know there are
people on the right who are very angry
with me when I say this because they
want to believe that President Trump is
totally right on all of us there's a
deep state coup that's happening and
Andy McCabe was part of this deep state
coup again you're gonna need the
evidence yeah I need the evidence to see
that in order for me to believe that and
there's a really good piece in The Wall
Street Journal about how truth has sort
of become tribal on both sides with
regard to American politics these days
that unfortunately people are believing
what they want to believe instead of
believing things are true and if you say
to them I need the evidence for that
then this shows that you're not true
this shows that you're not part of the
tribe and therefore you are disloyal
so I say president Trump makes an
assertion I won't know whether the
assertion is true this is a symptom of
my disloyalty whereas if I would just
say Trump said it and if people attack
him on the truth then it's even more
true because they're just attacking
Trump then you know then I would be I
guess to try
well I'm not into the tribal loyalty
thing as you may have noticed so I'm
going to ask again what McCabe's firing
has to do with robert muller and why the
president is connecting the two what's
even worse is the president Trump's
lawyer is coming out and saying the same
thing so his personal attorney on
Saturday called on Deputy Attorney
General Brad Rosen stands to shut down
the Special Counsel investigation into
Trump's campaign associates ties to
Russia listen I'm fine with the end of
this investigation but I think Trump
firing him is not going to be a good
look for him I'll explain why this is a
problem for Trump by his lawyer was was
saying stupid things in just a second
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at blue apron so blue
apron as you know is the leading meal
delivery ket in the United States is the
number one fresh ingredient recipe
delivery service in the country and
their mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible to everyone and right
now they offer a bunch of plans they
have a two-person meal plan a family
meal plan a wine plan they have all
sorts of great meals that are part of
their schedule and looking at the meals
right now the pictures of them you're
talking things like QuickView Catania
with broccoli and pecorino cheese
Italian style shrimp and sweet peppers
over for golus Arda pasta parmesan
crusted steaks with mashed potatoes and
broccoli may not be kosher but people in
the office say it's unbelievably
delicious and I'm telling you everybody
in the office is using it they offer
convenience and variety because they're
delivering fresh pre-portion ingredients
and step-by-step recipes right to your
door
they can be cooked in under 45 minutes
the minute the menu changes every single
week based on what's in season and is
designed by blue aprons in-house Killah
nari team they offer flexibility too so
twelve new recipes every week customers
can pick two three or four recipes based
on what best fits your schedule and all
the ingredients are the highest quality
you're gonna love it I mean I love
cooking with my kids you're gonna love
it even more when you don't have to go
to the market and figure out what you're
cooking instead it all comes packaged
fresh ready to go pre pre portion is
just fantastic blue apron calm /
Shapiro's and you get 30 bucks off your
first order that's blue apron calm /
appear oh use that promo clutch Shapiro
and you get $30 again off your first
order blue apron calm / appear oh it is
a better way to cook I also use that /
up here oh so they know that we sent you
as well okay so president Trump's
attorney came out John Dowd and he said
this quote I pray that acting Attorney
General Rosen Stein will follow the
brilliant and courageous example of the
FBI Office of Professional
Responsibility and Attorney General Jeff
Sessions and bring an end to alleged
Russia collusion investigation
manufactured by
cabe's boss james comey based upon a
fraudulent and corrupt dossier this is
what dad says just ends it on the merits
in light of recent revelations so I
guess the idea here is that we know that
mccabe is corrupt
we know that mccabe you know has
supposedly lied or at least Comey has
lied and so we are now going to
attribute to James Comey that he led off
the Muller investigation on bad evidence
and so we should end this sucker right
now again remember the Muller
investigation was not originally
predicated on the car page FISA warrant
that everybody is so hot and bothered
about originally it was predicated on
the george papadapolis surveillance
Papadopoulos was was a relatively
low-level staffer I think for the Trump
campaign there's not a lot of evidence
that he was a higher-up but he was
talking with Russian sources in London
who said that they could smuggle him
hillarie emails and then he was telling
that back to the Trump campaign that's
what led off this investigation in the
first place and again we still don't
know that everything in the steel
dossier that that the FISA warrant was
based on was false
well we know that some of it was false
we don't know the entire thing was false
we know that it was politically
motivated but a lot of Apple research is
politically motivated and that doesn't
necessarily mean that is false in in any
case should this investigation have been
had been begun on the evidence that we
now see I'm not sure that it should have
should it be ended on this basis well
it's very difficult politically for the
President of the United States to end
this investigation on the basis that
Annie McCabe got fired for a completely
separate reason and again there's a bit
of revisionist history going on here
okay the revisionist history is if this
was an attempt to get Trump if this was
always an attempt to get Trump if they
initiated this investigation in March
2016 I read as Trump was about to win
the nomination and the attempt was to
get Trump then why didn't any of this
leak until after Trump was already
elected president are the only stuff
that was coming out from the FBI during
the election cycle had nothing to do
with Trump it had to do instead with
Hillary Clinton remember James Comey is
the guy who basically sung killer his
chances it's amazing to watch as people
shift the narrative right so now Comey
is a favorite of the democrats again
when for a few minutes he was the worst
guy in the world according to Democrats
now James Comey is an absolutely
insufferable doof
so Comey came out in response to Trump
ripping into intima cave and into Comey
and into Muller and here's what he said
mr. president the American people will
hear my story very soon and they can
judge for themselves who is honorable
and who is not beside just one note for
James Comey who is just as I say
insufferable and this guy when when
Trump said that commis a grandstander
that is 100% true that
100% sure when he says that Comey is
sanctimonious that is certainly true how
do I know this because if James Comey
has such a great story to tell
why is he waiting for his book release
to tell it Haven is vitally important
that the American people know what James
Comey knows if it's vitally important
that the American people judge for
themselves
who is honorable and who is not then why
is James Comey waiting to show his book
why is he waiting at to get out there
and sell his book in these tours where
they're selling the tickets for a
hundred bucks a pop in order to tell his
story that doesn't sound like somebody
who's a deeply honorable guy that sounds
like a guy who's trying to make some
money on the side and make himself seem
honorable at the same time so it is
quite possible that there are no good
players here right it is quite possible
then nobody is doing anything right on
any of this and so Trump's own lawyers
started to walk this back Ty Cobb not
the great batsman for the for the
Detroit Tigers but Ty Cobb Trump's
lawyer he came out and he sort of backed
off John Dowd comments saying the Trump
should fire Muller
so Ty Cobb instead said Trump it turns
out is not actually discussing and
firing Muller so he came out and he
reversed himself right the White House
lawyer said in response to media
speculation and related questions being
posed to the administration the White
House yet again confirms that the
president is not considering or
discussing the firing of the special
counsel
Robert Muller visit is what he says okay
so that obviously is different from what
Trump's other lawyer said and then
Trump's other lawyer I love this came
out and said well I was speaking on my
own I'd really mean that was speaking
for Trump how many lawyers can come out
and say they're not speaking on behalf
of their client we now have one lawyer
of trumps who said he didn't pay off a
porn star on behalf of President Trump
and now we have another lawyer says he
wasn't speaking on behalf of President
Trump it is not good to be an agent in
fact for the President of the United
States that is certainly true well
meanwhile there there people who are who
are making the obvious point here which
is that if Trump wants to look innocent
here he should just shut up right if
Trump wants to look innocent here you
should let the wheels of justice grind
exceedingly small trey Gowdy makes this
point trey Gowdy of course is a hardcore
right winger right from South Carolina
he's the head of the House Oversight
Committee and here's what he had to say
about Trump's lawyers coming on talking
about Muller Chris if you look at the
jurisdiction for Robert Mahler first and
foremost what did Russia do to this
country in 2016 that is supremely
important and it has nothing to do with
collusion so to suggest
Muller should shut down and that all he
is looking at is collusion if you have
an innocent client mr dout act like it
that's exactly right I mean the fact
that the fact that Gowdy is saying is
how could I'm saying I take it as a
point of pride because the reality is
that Trump should stop with all the
sudden Republicans are saying this to
Republicans senators are now warning the
president not to fire Muller
they say the president has to let the
federal investigate the investigators
finish what they're doing again I think
a lot of this has to do with Trump just
being annoyed I think he fired Comey
because he was annoyed I don't think
this is all planned out again I don't
think you can have it both ways if
you're a Democrat either Trump is a doof
we just does things on the spur of the
moment or Trump is a master manipulator
behind the scenes working with Putin the
guy can't even capitalize correctly and
I'm gonna go with he's just a dupe doing
things on the spur of the moment because
I think that that fits the evidence a
little bit better then he is nefariously
plotting everything Jeff Flake who's
become a rather irritating figure he
came out and he said the McCabe's firing
was a horrible day for democracy of
course he said this on CNN well when the
president said it was a great day for
democracy yesterday I think it was a
horrible day for democracy to have
firings like this happening at the top
from the president and the Attorney
General does not speak well for what's
going on so I don't know what the
designs are on Muller but it seems to be
building toward that and I just hope it
doesn't go there I don't think it's
going to go there I think a lot of this
is loose talk by the president because
the president does a lot of loose talk
but hey I've been proved wrong before
the president usually has about a
six-month time delay he's got one of
these president Trump's policies or at
least his firings the staff and policies
are sort of like one of those cartoon
bombs and Bugs Bunny cartoon where you
like the wick and it's eight miles long
and then it takes a year for the bottom
actually to go off it's possible that's
what Trump is doing it's also possible
that he's just talking like Trump talked
I do love the Jeff Flake looks like he
just stayed a little bit late at a
wedding and had to make it on time for
the State of the Union for the State of
the Union hit again I think a lot of
this is Trump being frustrated is what
Reuters is reporting White House
legislative affairs director Mark short
said the Trump team was fully
cooperating in the Muller investigation
and that the president was expressing
his growing frustration with how long
the probe has lasted there's a shock
right Lindsey Graham meanwhile says that
Muller shouldn't be dismissed except for
cause Trump has drawn a lot of criticism
and of course senator Rubio
says they doesn't like the way that
McCabe was fired he says that he should
have been allowed to finish through the
weekends I'm not sure that makes a big
difference again the OPR is a relatively
nonpartisan apparently it's a pretty
clean nonpartisan group so III have a
tough time saying that yeah that it has
to do with with sessions just wanting to
get again sessions has been pretty
stalwart and not allowing Trump to
interfere with my work she's been pretty
stalwart in not getting rid of rod
Rosenstein he's been pretty stalwart and
not getting rid of McCabe until the
evidence came out from the Office of
Professional Responsibility so all of
the talk about how Trump's people are
acting is his lackeys in this I just I
don't see the evidence for that at all
okay meanwhile there's a story that came
out over the weekend that got all sorts
of press and I'm not really sure why
yeah let me correct I have a very strong
feeling why but I don't think it's the
reason that a lot of other people are
saying so there's a story that came out
from the UK Guardian about Cambridge
analytic Cambridge analytical was the
data from the president Trump was using
during his election and it's also been
used by the Heritage Foundation
originally I believe it was used by the
Cruz campaign and the idea was that they
were nefariously gathering data from
Facebook so it's a very long article by
a woman named Carol Cadwallader and it's
about a guy named Christopher Wiley who
is a who's an openly gay guy who worked
with Steve Bannon and I guess maybe my
lowly innopolis he said that he
described a tool on Facebook called
Steve Bannon psychological warfare
MINDEF tool yeah now as you know I am no
fan of Steve bannon's I think Steve
Bannon is one of the worst person one
with most persons I have ever met my
life thing is well worse people ever I
think Steve is garbage but this story
does not hold up to scrutiny I'll
explain why in just second first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
stamps.com
so right now you can get everything on
demand right this podcast is on demand
you're gonna get your TV on demand you
can cut the cable but you still have to
go to the post office to mail letters
and packages but you don't have to do
that anymore thanks to stamps con so
lots of great services at the post
offices but why wait in line
stamps calm make sure that you can
access all the amazing services of the
post office right from your desk 24/7
when it is convenient for you buy and
print official US postage for any letter
any package using your own computer and
printer and the mail carrier just picks
it up you just click print mail you're
done could not be easier you print it
out right
to a sticker you put the sticker on the
envelope you prints it right onto the
envelope and prints it out onto a piece
of paper tape it onto the envelope and
it'll send you the scale as well so that
you can always send with exact postage
we use it here at the Daily wire offices
on a regular basis to send important
letters and packages we use it to send
merch sometimes right now use Shapiro
for this special offer it includes $55 a
free postage a digital scale and a four
week trial so it's a pretty spectacular
deal go to right now stamps calm and use
promo code Shapiro right you click on
the radio microphone at the top of your
homepage right when you got to stamps
comm and you type in Shapiro and when
you do you get 55 bucks of free postage
which is a solid deal a digital scale
and a four week trial
you get that right now at stamps comm
and again click on the radio mic and use
that promo code up here to get the
special deal means you never have to go
to the post office again and wait in
line and get all those great services
just in the privacy and comfort of your
own home again stamps comm promo code
Shapiro when you click on that radio
microphone at the top of the page that
also lets them know that we sent you
okay so this story basically alleges
that there was some sort of evil
nefarious corruption going on inside the
Trump campaign with regard to data
operations so again the UK Guardian is
reporting that in 2014 Steve Bannon was
Wiley's boss okay the guy who were
talking about here's again him
Christopher Wiley who is a pink haired
guy I mean that's this part of the
article is a pink haired guy who was
apparently some sort of computer genius
and Robert Mercer was the guy who was
funding Cambridge analytical the idea
they brought in they brought in they
bought into was to bring big data and
social media to an established military
methodology information operations then
turn it on the US electorate it was
Wiley who came up with that idea and
oversaw its realization it was Wiley who
became the source for the UK Guardian
and here's here's what it basically says
apparently he ended up showing the
author a tranche of documents that laid
out secret workings behind Cambridge
analytical in the month following
publication it was revealed that the
company had reached out to WikiLeaks to
help distribute Hillary Clinton's stolen
emails in 2016 and then we watched as it
became subject to a special council
investigation it's possible Russian
collusion in the u.s. election The
Observer also received the first of
three letters from Cambridge analytical
threatening to sue Guardian news and
media for defamation we're still only
just starting to understand the males
from the forces that came together to
create the conditions from what Muller
confirmed last month was information
warfare but Wiley offers a unique
worm's-eye view of the events
20:16 of how Facebook was hijacked
repurposed to become a theater of war
how became a launchpad for what seems to
be an extraordinary attack on the US is
democratic the process okay so what
exactly is that extraordinary attack he
says that they broke Facebook what
exactly did they do well apparently they
sends out a couple of links on Facebook
that allowed them to gather information
that's pretty much it apparently all
they really did I mean they bury the
lead all the way down in this story you
know in the middle of his in the middle
of this long biography of who this guy
is but essentially all they did was they
put out things like IQ tests and
personality quizzes that give you access
to somebody's Facebook right you you've
had these before somebody will send you
to a site and it'll say take this
personality quiz and they'll say do you
want to access this personality quiz
through Facebook so you say yes right
well now they have informaiton the
information on your profile that's not
illegal
you can sent it to it it's not a big
deal that's all Cambridge general it
could did they put out some of these
quizzes they gathered all the
information and then they had all this
profile information of people that
wasn't political information per se but
it was personality information and
personality gauges pretty highly with
politics it tracks pretty highly with
posix they're a bunch of studies that
suggest that if you like certain types
of food or if you like certain types of
music then that's likely to mean that
you are of a particular political party
for example so Christopher Wylie is one
of the guys who was who's designing all
of this so in 2013 while he met Steve
Bannon and he apparently said that
Bannon got it immediately and so he
decided to pitch the Mercer's on making
cambridge analytical the the nexus for
doing all of this stuff right Enbridge
analytical would be the the great cyber
warfare nexus so Robert Mercer was going
to pour millions of dollars they flew to
New York to meet the Mercer's in
Rebecca's Manhattan apartment and Wiley
said she loved me she was like oh we
need more of your type on her side your
type of the gays she loved the gays so
did Steve he saw his early adopters he
figured if you can get the gays on board
everyone else will follow
it's why he was into the whole Milo
thing so Robert Mercer was very into it
so what did Wiley do so apparently what
while he did was he he executed a
contract with SEL which is the parent
company of Cambridge analytical which
shows them we're in a commercial
agreement with a company called global
science research owned by Cambridge
based academic Alexander Cogan
specifically premise Thanh the
harvesting and processing of Facebook
data so that could be matched to
personality traits and voter
Cambridge analytical spent seven million
dollars to amass the data about 1
million of it 1 million of it with the
global research center ok global science
research he has the bank records and
wire transfers emails reveal while he
first negotiated with Michal kasinski
one of the co-authors of the original my
personality research paper to use the my
personality database and then they
replicated the information in that
database and then they built up a store
of data now what exactly apparently they
collected millions of profiles in a
matter of weeks ok but none of this is
illegal and there's and there's nothing
here that's illegal now as soon as
widely reported this Facebook
immediately suspended him so here's the
real question why are the media covering
this I'm not seeing anything here that
says to me something deeply nefarious
and horrible went on it looks like data
gathering that was done by the Obama
camp I'm sure in 2012 and in 2008 you
know this was playing catch-up on the
right for all the data banking that had
been done on the left one of the big
criticisms of the Romney campaign in
2012 that their information system was
so bad that their data analytics were so
weak and so Trump was trying to fight
that and Bannon was trying to fight that
which seems to me a smart thing to do
not an illegal thing to do so why
exactly is everybody focusing on this
I'll tell you the answer that everybody
is focusing in on non illegal behavior
by Cambridge analytical is because they
don't want to pressure Cambridge
analytical they want to pressure
Facebook and they want to pressure of
Facebook and they want to pressure
YouTube and they want a pressure Google
and they want to pressure Twitter there
there's a massive attack on
conservatives going on right now in
social media
Facebook's traffic they've used their
new algorithm to target people on the
right who are open about the right-wing
views if you are a quote-unquote
objective site then they have not
targeted you in the same way there was a
study that came out last week
demonstrating that major sites I'm
talking about everybody from Breitbart
to Daily wire has been targeted by
Facebook and then our traffic has
dropped pretty precipitously for all of
those sites right Daily Caller the blaze
all of these every single right-wing
site saw a major hit in traffic since
Facebook Institute its new algorithm
wanna know what didn't see a major drop
in traffic you wanna know it didn't see
any drop in traffic essentially the
folks on the Left they saw virtually no
drop in traffic whatsoever which is not
surprising why would they see a drop in
traffic after all Facebook is a
left-wing outlet and the goal here is to
pressure Facebook right Diane
Feinstein's and pressuring Facebook and
now the media are gonna say Cambridge
analytical use Facebook they better
crack down on these right-wingers these
right-wingers
we're doing data mining they better find
a way to crack down that's what this is
all about it's about militarizing Google
and Facebook and YouTube and Twitter
it's why louis farrakhan is still being
recommended as they follow for a lot of
people including me right I'll be it
because I've tweeted about Louis
Farrakhan it will recommend that I
followed Louis Farrakhan he's not being
suspended from Twitter but you know
who's suspended from Twitter steven
crowder for a week and all of these
algorithms are being built by left
wingers and whether they whether they
know it or not they are biased against
right wingers and it is really gross him
pretty soon there's gonna be no choice
but for people on the right to build
their own fora for distribution of
material if this continues because it
truly is an insane thing I want to
discuss a little bit more about that
plus an update on parkland which just
demonstrates once again this is not
about the guns this is about the failure
of the authorities but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
wonder ease this is war so yeah you want
to subscribe to a brand new podcast that
it's just fantastic that is that this is
war podcast this is war follows a bunch
of soldiers from Afghanistan and Iraq
and it lets them tell their first-hand
accounts of what it's like to fight and
survive in foreign lands protecting our
freedom the bonds that they form the
psychological it takes on a human beings
what it's like to return home how do you
fit in how do you heal both physically
and emotionally from having to fight in
the first episode you meet a guy named
Ian Mirren's and month before his senior
year in high school he decided to join
up in the military there's August of
2001 and then of course his life utterly
changed September of 2001 there's so
many wonderful stories that need to be
told about our soldiers and this is war
does it go over - this is war on Apple
podcasts or wherever you're listening to
this or visit wonder afm slash been
that's wonder with yfm slash man that's
one dree dot F M slash been subscribe
listen it's fantastic it's moving and I
think that it's it's necessary so check
it out this is war on Apple podcast
please subscribe or go over to wonder
EFM slash man that's wonder read dot F M
slash been use the slash pen so that
they know that we sent you as well okay
so I do want to discuss a little bit
more about what's going on in power
climb because this is a pretty
astonishing story that came out plus I
want to talk about the Russian elections
but first you're gonna have to go over
to daily wire calm right now and
subscribe $9.99 a month get to a
subscription to daily wire.com you get
the rest of this show live get the rest
of Cleveland's show the rest of
Knowles's execrable show you get all of
those things live you get to be part of
our mailbag what you do on fridays we're
gonna have great discounts coming up for
people who are subscribers really cool
stuff coming for our subscribers
so if you want to get the annual
subscription get all of those Plus this
the greatest in all beverage vessels the
leftist tears hot or cold beverage
vessel it is just magic and sheer magic
the magic of tumblers check it out you
get the annual subscription or if you
just want to listen for later for free
go over to iTunes please subscribe leave
us a review apple podcast please go over
there subscribe leave us a review go
over to Facebook and on YouTube make
sure you subscribe on YouTube leave us a
review
we always appreciate we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
all righty so the parkland authorities
apparently is an amazing story
apparently the authorities actually knew
not only the power clan and shooter was
an evil piece of garbage but they wanted
to institutionalize him two years before
he shot up that school in parkland
Florida
according to Ryan's Vedra over at Daily
wire shocking new details about the
gunman who shot up Marjorie Stoneman
Douglas High School released on Sunday
it was revealed that officials from the
school and a sheriff's deputy
recommended that he be forcibly
committed to a psychiatric facility two
years before his rampage nothing was
ever done the AP says the documents
which are part of the gunman's criminal
case in the shooting show that he had
written the word kill in a notebook told
the classmate he wanted to buy a gun and
use it and had cut his arm supposedly in
anger because he had broken up with a
girlfriend he also told another student
he had drunk gasoline and was throwing
up calls had been made to the FBI about
the possibility of the gunman using a
gun at school the gunman's mother Linda
is quoted as saying she had fresh
concerns about her son's mental state
after he punched holes in a wall at
their home in parkland the clinicians at
Henderson came to the home for
interviews and said the gunman admitted
punching the wall but said he did so
because he was upset and a breakup with
his girlfriend the documents say the
gunman quote reports that he cut his
arms three to four weeks ago and states
that this is the only time he has ever
cut the gunman states that he cut
because he was lonely
states that he had broken up with his
girlfriend and reports that his grades
had fallen if he'd been
institutionalized we've been very
difficult for him to purchase a firearm
just garbage dropped by the authorities
as always again this is not about giving
the authorities more authority to do the
right thing this is about ensuring that
law-abiding people can protect
themselves when the authorities fail as
it is apparent they do pretty much every
time at this point they're failing on a
regular basis it truly is a horrifying
horrifying thing now meanwhile there's a
big election last night in Russia when I
say election I mean selection because
it's pretty obvious who exactly was
going to win and we all know the answer
to that one right the person who is
going to win clearly was going to be
Vladimir Putin and so it was and so it
hovers Shelby so Putin has now been in
power since 1999 he's been in power for
almost 20 years
I don't count to me to remember the
dev's reign in Russia as natural reign
who's obviously a puppet of Putin and as
everybody knew including President Obama
so Putin has been continuously in power
for twenty years there are so many
points to be made about this it's really
quite fascinating the first point to
make is number one obviously there's
some rigging going on
in these elections and when people know
it's inevitable the Putin's gonna be
elected they're not even gonna show up
here's some video of some of the
election rigging okay so you can see
here's a woman walking over and stuffing
ballots into the ballot box right and
then you can see another woman who takes
out another ballot actually hands it to
the lady they look at this they're just
taking ballots and shoving them into the
ballot box none of these people have
voted all right they're literally just
walking over there and shoving ballots
into the into the ballot box so yeah
this is all perfectly legit though don't
worry nothing nothing nefarious going on
here at all they're legitimately just
stuffing ballots into the ballot box
yeah don't though everything's cool
everything's aboveboard over there in
Russia Garry Kasparov who's been a
dissident for a long time obviously
world famous chess player may be the
greatest chess player in history now he
says these elections are a sham because
of course they are a charade is the only
road that Madison indicates what Russia
is Putin's world so you were right
showing him voting for himself and
that's it you're absolutely right saying
that they turn out is the only challenge
it's socially because of apathy because
many people are scared actually to show
up and and to demonstrate that they
disapprove Putin's policies of course
that's true I mean I'd be afraid too if
I were living in Russia considering that
Putin has legitimately murdered people
with weapons of mass destruction abroad
right I mean the man poisoned apparently
a Soviet dissident a Russian dissident
and not too long ago that there's a
false spring in Russia that happened
right as the Soviet Union fell and now
they have fallen right back into what
can only be described as a state
capitalism tyranny it looks a lot more
like China over in Russia than it looks
like the United States as far as state
control of the economy is an Oleg Archy
run by all of Latin Americans friends
and a lot of that was a reaction that
there's a lot of it is a feeling in
Russia of a romantic nationalism it's
really fascinating article in The Wall
Street Journal today really really
interesting or a couple days ago over
the weekend about how Russian people
particularly young Russian people feel
about Vladimir Putin and the reason that
this is important is for a couple of
reasons first it's important because we
in the United States are in the midst of
what people are saying is a youth
revolution very very important that all
the youth of America be treated with
respect because these are experts on
politics these are people who know
whereof they speak and young people are
passionate I mean been reading you over
the last couple of weeks op-ed after
op-ed
idiot saying that young people are more
passionate we can only hope to give the
future to them hey Putin's people are
the young people the young people like
Putin is the Wall Street Journal quote
and to keep that you've live doesn't
really follow politics but the high
school student says he's sure that only
President Vladimir Putin can manage a
country as big as Russia anastasia
Kalina who is studying law values the
peace and stability of mr. Putin's rule
and is thrilled with new shopping malls
in her hometown Darya Shova says Russian
life is better and freer than in the
past when we talk with our parents
they're sometimes shocked by the
numerous opportunities we have today the
three young people like all Russians of
their generation have no no leader other
than the former KGB colonel who is on
track to win another six-year term in
presidential elections on Sundays over
the course of their lives
Putin has transformed Russia from that
times chaotic democracy to an
authoritarian state he's written a new
social contract that offers citizens far
better living standards and restored
swagger on the world stage while
limiting political freedoms polls
sociological research and interviews
with more than a dozen young Russians in
four cities reveal a generation largely
at ease with that trade-off there there
though there are those who are
browbeaten dissenters and they have some
polls on this ok this is really it it's
shocking ok so here are the approvals
for Vladimir Putin in Russia okay so the
the approval among young people
particularly okay this is the popularity
eighty-one percent to prove right now
and disapprove 18 percent in Russia as
of right now ok if that doesn't sound
legitimate it's because no one anywhere
has that sort of popularity unless you
are actually a tyrant by age group
here's by age group sees vastly popular
across Russia but he is most popular
with young people but 18 to 24 s approve
of Vladimir Putin at the highest rate
followed by 25 to 39 s followed by 55 s
and over right there has been a rise in
living standards they have slipped since
2014 a lot of that was based on Russia's
oil booms so thanks to fracking the
prices of oil in Russia dropped
precipitously and that stopped a lot of
the growth in Russia the percentage of
total population with a monthly income
below subsistence level has been
dropping precipitously since 2000 thanks
to the oil oligarchy that exists in
Russia but again the popularity of Putin
is largely linked to the fact that he is
not only you know ensuring that a lot of
the oil money is going to various public
services but also the fact that
Putin is restoring a sense of national
importance and greatness there's an
there's something in human history it
happened really with the French
Revolution with regard to something
called romantic nationalism romantic
nationalism was the idea that your
country is not only better than other
countries because of the ideas it
espouses it is better because of its
language it is better because of its its
people it is is it's this idea of
nationalism without patriotism Russia
isn't great because it promulgates great
values Russia is great because it
deserves to be great because Russia is
great America is great in the same way
right this is the way that Barack Obama
used to speak of American exceptionalism
everyone believes in their own
exceptionalism there is a baseline level
of truth to that that really started
with the French Revolution so the French
Revolution changed everything and in
order to sort of understand what's been
going on in Russian politics I think you
actually have to go back 200 years and
look at a little bit of the history of
romantic nationalism so when the French
Revolution first broke out there was a
feeling that something magical was
happening we're at the French Revolution
which began in 1789 with the fall of the
Bastille
that just months actually after the
after the first meetings of the US
Senate under the US Constitution is
pretty amazing when that happened there
was a feeling of international there's
gonna be the International rise in
freedom the French movement wasn't just
French it was international it was
global it was Universal and that quickly
shifted into something else it quickly
shifted into a romantic nationalism that
romantic nationalism really took hold
around 1793 in France when there was a
threat from a foreign war from the
Austrians so the Austrians thought they
were gonna waltz right into France and
restore the monarchy in France and they
were going to be able to take over the
new French Republic because it was so
chaotic and because it was crazy and
because it was it was led by all of
these nutjob radicals and so the French
instituted something that had never been
done before in world history hey general
draft of the population what was called
the levy on mass that happened in 1793
and when they did that when they issued
the levy on mass they gathered 1.5
million people 1.5 million people were
essentially drafted by the French
government and the French were able to
fight off all invaders they were able to
throw off all comers it was an amazing
thing and it totally shifted the balance
of power in Europe because suddenly he
had a country that was treating all of
its citizens as part of the state
bargain and it's treating all of its
citizens
as as their individuals identity were
wrapped up in the identity of the state
this sort of romantic nationalism was
also being pursued in what was then not
quite Germany yet it was still it was
still Austria and during some of the
German states and Prussia it was being
pursued by people like Hegel at the time
a little bit later it was Hegel but at
the time there was a romantic
nationalism that was being pushed that
said that Germany you should only speak
German Germany is a special place and
therefore Germany should have its own
pan national state of Germans you can
see how this played out during the 20th
century
well these sorts of feelings in the
human heart or feelings that were
described by George Orwell in 1940 with
regard to the Nazis what he was
wondering was why is it that there are
so many people who are who are in the
Nazi regime who are young when they
could be part of Britain right they
could be part of a global movement
toward capitalism and freedom and toward
prosperity a sort of middle class
existence and what he said was there's
part of the human heart that wants the
flags at once the drums that wants the
blood that wants the toil that wants the
sacrifice okay there is that feeling
today in Russia too if you look at the
polls Stalin is still very much admired
inside Russia and one of the reasons
that he is so very much admired inside
Russia is because Stalin stood for
national greatness would you want to
live in a country that that wasn't great
it was prosperous but it was Switzerland
we'd want to live in Switzerland would
you live one live in the country that
felt like it had a historical purpose
and when Hegel talked about the world
history and how states were the great
drivers of this history how states were
the the the main forces behind pushing
for progress in history and that
progress in history was proof of God
when he said that there were a lot of
people who resonate to that on a normal
on a normative level who say that's how
I want my state to be I want my state to
be a driver in world history and at
least you could justify your own poverty
of living in the Soviet Union by saying
well we're trying something new a grand
experiment at least we're trying
something new at least we're powerful at
least we're threatening the United
States on the world stage that's how
powerful we are those big bad us greedy
pokes we're challenging them every
single day
well when the Soviet Union collapsed so
while that purpose went away there's a
great book called secondhand time I
recommend it on the show before and that
book talks with Russians before during
after the Cold War and what they say is
that there's a certain nostalgia that
exists in Russia for a time when the
Russia was a great
power and now Putin gets to kind of
pretend that Russia is still a great
power and this is something that drives
a lot of young people a lot of young
people are interested in that well the
problem with believing that our country
must be a great power without any excuse
for actually being in great power you're
not spreading Liberty you're not
spreading democracy you're not doing
anything great is that it leads to war
it leads to an unborn nationalism that
turns very quickly into something
violent and terrible and that's why
Putin is constantly invading countries
around him it's why he's invading Crimea
it's why the folks in Kazakhstan should
be particularly worried or Azerbaijan
there are a lot of states that border so
the former Soviet Union that are in
danger right it's why Croatia it's why
Latvia Lithuania why those states are
particularly worried right now because
Putin is trying to demonstrate to his
public that he's part of this romantic
nationalism movement brought to the
brought to the fore once again history
repeats itself
Putin is more comedy than tragedy but
not by much and so you know that's the
old saying is that tragedy is that
history repeats itself the first time is
tragedy the second time is comedy Putin
again is not comedy he's closer to it
than Stalin was but all of this is to
say that there is a yearning in the
human heart that is not being met you're
earning in the human heart that is not
being a film and it's being filled
globally speaking with a certain level
of romantic nationalism with a certain
level of tribalism with a return to
socialistic ideas without God and this
is really disturbing it's not just
happening there it's happening here to
the romantic nationalism movement that
says that America is great not because
of any of its founding principles but
just because America's America maybe the
the the folks who say that America ought
to move toward equality because equality
is what's going to fill that hole in the
heart you know and then I don't mean
social equality I mean equality of
finance now all of this stuff is
indicative of a greater ill that is
plaguing humanity right now I'm writing
an entire book on it right now but the
romantic nationalism that's taking place
in Russia is something that should not
be ignored nor can it be ignored if you
actually want to understand what's going
on
okay so meanwhile Democrats are still
trying to figure out exactly what it is
they should do in the wake of Hillary
Clinton so as you recall last week
Hillary Clinton came forward and
suggested that she was only not
President of the United States because
of these evil terrible horrible no good
very bad Hicks and rednecks and their
wives we're living in the middle of the
country well now she issued a very very
long statement because she
never issued a short statement talking
about why she was wrong
but she doesn't really apologize she
says during the interview last week with
an Indian news publication I was asked
about 2016 and whether Trump is the
virus or a symptom of something deeper
going on in American society
like most Americans people overseas
remain shocked and dismayed at what they
are witnessing daily my first instinct
was to defend Americans and explain how
Donald Trump could have been elected I
said the place is doing better
economically typical alien Democrat and
places where there is less optimism
about the future lean Republican that
doesn't mean the coast versus the
heartland it doesn't even mean entire
states in fact it's more often captures
the divisions between more dynamic urban
areas and less prosperous small towns
within states and what's hilarious about
this is this is supposed to be her
apology but instead she just doubles
down on all of this and says that so to
those who are upset or offended by what
I said last week I hope this explanation
helps to explain the point I was trying
to make we all got it lady we all got
the point that you were trying to make
that's the problem you wish we didn't
get it
no wonder Democrats are running for her
Mary Hart who was a former spokesperson
for the State Department under Obama she
came for and said Hillary should please
just go away like enough you're right
and she should go away I hate to say
that I really do the first female
nominee of a major party has historical
you know role certainly and the right to
speak up she is not helping the
Democratic Party and I think she should
take a very long vacation and leave the
future of the party to other people I
think the future of the party is not
with her and the clearest indication of
that is the fact that in the 20 special
elections that have taken place so far
in 2018 Democrats on average have gotten
24 more points than she did
the party of the future is not Hillary
Clinton's party and I get why she wants
to keep explaining it but it is not
usually okay so even Democrats are
starting to realize they need to move
away from Hillary Clinton if they hope
to be successful in the future okay time
for some things I like and then some
things that I hate and then we will get
to the the Federalist Papers so things
that I like so I had the opportunity to
interview Charlotte pence about her new
book which is called Marlin bundo is a
day in the life of the vice president
her mom did the art Charlotte pence
wrote it so Charlotte is my pence
daughter Karen pence is my penses wife
and the book is really charming I read
my daughter over the weekend she really
enjoyed it so here is my sit-down with
Charlotte pence so here we are with
Charlotte pence she's the author
of Marlon bundo is a day in the life of
the vice-president which is a children's
book as you could probably guess from
the title and it's illustrated by Karen
pence is of course the vice president's
wife and Charlotte if you didn't guess
was the vice president's daughter as
well uh well Charlotte welcome to the
show thank you for having me so first
question is and I was seriously
considering this a little bit earlier
why Marlin bundo as opposed to Rabbit de
niro there's actually a good answer for
that when we got Marlin I we had him in
a student film project so I had to go on
Craigslist and get a bunny and so I was
texting the Craigslist owner and he said
she made him an offer so it became his
Godfather joke we were gonna make him an
offer he couldn't refuse and my friend
loved marlon brando and i said we have
to name it marlon bun dough to make it
you know okay so where'd the idea for
the act for actually doing a book on the
rabbit come in yeah
so we started an Instagram for him right
after the inauguration and she's got
pretty popular people really liked him
we kind of made this bonus joke that he
was you know having official duties as
the bonus and so my mom and I talked
about doing a children's book and her
illustrating it and she's an amazing
watercolor artist and so we just went
for it and we were brainstorming ideas
and said you know the first one at least
should definitely be about the role of
the vice president because a lot of
people don't actually know the official
duties of the vice president so that's
all in there
that's really cool so yeah so how long's
your mama doing watercolors because that
is definitely something that oh my god
nobody knows yeah forever I mean ever
since I've been alive I mean she used to
have a business for it she's a really
talented artist not just watercolor
artist she's amazing
so okay so you're gonna be doing a book
tour with this presumably yeah and and I
hope that everybody treats you well
because obviously it's a very polarized
political environment do you expect that
it's going to get politicized when you
do the book tour you hope it I mean I
kind of think that Marlon can bring
everyone together like I mean the book
is it's historically accurate it's good
for teachers it's good for adults it's
good for kids it is personal to my dad a
day in a life of the vice-president with
my dad as you can kind of see at the end
is his faith comes into it but for the
most part
it talks about what the vice-president
actually does which is I think something
I didn't really know until my dad was
vice president a lot of these little
things well so it's so one of the things
that's really cool about your family is
that all of the kids have different
things that they do so I've met two of
the of the pence children yeah and and
none of you seem to be supremely
politically active as opposed to just
active in different areas of what you do
so how's it been having your father in
the White House I mean it's like a
boring answer but I mean he's just my
dad at the end of the day so I feel like
I mean growing up it was always like
this is my dad's job you know my mom's a
teacher and my dad it's a congressman
for most of my childhood and so we were
always included in whatever we wanted to
be included in as the kids but we also
didn't have to do anything we didn't
want to do and go to any event we didn't
want to go to so at the end of the day
it's really it's our family my dad you
know we talk about current events on the
phone we're catching up but then we talk
about you know what I got at the grocery
or whatever and at the end of the day's
just my dad yeah and you work out here
in Hollywood so how is that been how
people treat did you do something in
Hollywood yeah I mean really they have I
think that once you meet people you know
you get to know people better on a
personal level I think that always
brings people together and sort of
seeing someone from a political lens on
on TV or in magazines or something I
think I've been welcomed out here in my
job especially
it's it's been fun well that's awesome
I've been enough man really family do
you have an amazing family and and
obviously this is a book that you should
get for your children it is Marlon bundo
is a day in the life of the vice
president written by Charlotte pence and
illustrated by Karen thanks so much for
stopping by really appreciate me this is
awesome so that was fun so that
Charlotte pence who is just a charming
young woman and her family is really
filled with wonderful people okay other
things that I like so I just have to
play a clip of this because it was funny
I was on CNN yesterday and my phone did
go off in the middle of the interview
the real move the real power move
would've been a pickup and just take the
call in the middle of the interview but
I I didn't have my wits about me enough
to do that but to brian Stelter
unreliable sources asked me about bias
and the media and I said you guys that
would be you well over the last three
weeks obviously the coverage of the gun
debate
has been absolutely egregious and I want
to single out your network it's you know
it's been pretty bad on this from a
conservative perspective the the idea
that when there's a mass shooting that
the media feel the necessity to put on
TV not only survivors but specific
survivors that there's a certain subset
of survivors who make it on TV a lot a
lot and there are certain other
survivors who don't and that they
decided to single out certain events and
not other events in order to make a
particular case or they allow certain
people to go on TV and suggest that
folks like Dana lash or people at the
NRA are evil don't care they're
terrorists and there's no pushback from
the anchors you know this sort of thing
makes a lot of people on the right feel
that the media are really using this as
an opportunity to push gun control
rather than objectively covering you
know the the legislative efforts that
are going on in Washington DC okay so
that was a lot of fun and I give a lot
of credit to Stelter for having me on he
knew that I was gonna hit CNN he didn't
mind so good for him for doing that
because obviously he wanted to have some
different voices he did say my favorite
part of this interview is where he
suggested well if we the daily we're so
critical of the mainstream media why
don't we try to infiltrate the
mainstream media and then you and then
try and shift them and my answer memos
are you going to hire me like really is
he and I'm gonna hire me because they
have my phone number anytime they want
to they can call and offer me a
prime-time show I'm going to seriously
too helped that that is in CNN's blends
anytime soon which sort of proves my
point
okay so time for a quick thing that I
hate and then we'll get to a federalist
paper if we have time if not then we'll
do it tomorrow so okay so the thing I
hate today is Oprah Winfrey was on with
Stephen Colbert and it is just amazing
to me how late-night TV has become an
exclusive propaganda outlet for the left
Stephen Colbert obviously has been a
lefty for a very long time and an
irritating lefty at that really really
irritating lefty of that so it's amazing
because folks on TV will rip Mike Pence
up and down for suggesting that he has
conversations with God meaning he talks
to God and God does the listening or he
attempts to hear God in the events of
his own life you know how crazy is that
that's wild right but Stephen Colbert
when Oprah Winfrey says I'm waiting for
God to give me a sign Stephen Colbert
actually tries to manufacture God and
then pretend that God is telling Oprah
Winfrey to run this is what Democrats
would love best I would love nothing
better than for Oprah Winfrey to run
first of all I think Trump would smoke
her I think it would just be brutal
again Trump is as dirty as dirty can be
and Oprah is perceived as angelic figure
the minute that anybody finds out that
her that her school in South Africa has
been twice hit with serious violations
of sexual abuse of children she's pretty
much toast so even though she may not be
responsible for it that's what's been
going on with her school over in Africa
so that's a problem for her but again
anything anyone says bad about Oprah is
going to make her look a lot dirtier
than anything anyone says about Trump I
mean Trump's been hit with everything
including the kitchen sink and none of
it seems to stick to him in any serious
way in any case here is Colbert
mimicking God in order to try to
convince hilber to run is there
something you'd like to tell Oprah oh
yeah I hear thou seekest a sign well is
this clear enough how do I make this
clearer Oprah oh I know Oprah Winfrey
yes okay so now you have late night
hosts openly stumping for Oprah Winfrey
to run against President Trump yeah and
in doing so by mocking God and people of
faith so that's that's just wonderful
well done Stephen Colbert that's not
gonna alienate anybody in the middle of
the country or anything well then okay
quick Federalist paper good news this
one will take me less than 30 seconds so
Federalist number 20 ever we've been
going through a Federalist paper this is
a continuation of the argument regarding
the ineffectiveness of Confederacy right
the idea that you can't have a bunch of
powerful sovereign actors and then a
very weak coalitional government at the
top and he uses this James Madison using
the example of United Netherlands and he
adds this telling line a weak
Constitution must necessarily terminate
in dissolution from want of proper
powers or the usurpation of powers
requisite for the public safety whether
the usurpation when once begun will stop
at the salutary point or go forward to
the dangerous extreme it must depend on
the contingencies at the moment tyranny
has perhaps often or grown out of
assumptions of power called for on
pressing exigencies by a defective
Constitution than out of the full
exercise of the largest constitutional
authorities this is a fantastic point
and is historically true most tyrannies
begin by saying the current system is
not working we need to move the mcurtin
system aside and overrun its boundaries
so suspension of habeas corpus during
the Civil War would
an example of this although we went back
to habeas corpus afterward or the
seizure of emergency powers by Hitler's
Nazis in 1933 in 1934 right all of that
would be a perfect example of what
Madison was talking about that when you
don't have a properly balanced
government even if the government
appears to be too weak centrally very
often people will say the exigencies of
the circumstances demand that we do X
and X is usually a permanent enlargement
of the government every time America has
a major war there's an enlargement of
the government this goes even so far as
the Patriot Act during a 9/11 it's why
we must be so careful particularly
during times of emergency about having
the government extra powers alrighty
we'll be back here tomorrow broadcasting
I believe from Pennsylvania so we'll see
you then
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Aleksandr Oh
audios mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018